What will happen to cetes in 2 024 They will probably continue to
hover around 11 point 25 performance until mid-March From there they
would gradually begin the decline Awaiting the banjico announcement March 21.
On that day,
specialists expect the bank of Mexico to begin its rate cut cycle.
This means that from then on,
TCs would continue to perform lower each month.
The good news is that even if that day begins the fall the market expects
CT to close in 2024 paying at 1 9 per 100 or more depending on the term
And when you consider that for this year we expect a correction of 4% it
leaves us with a decent real profit of 5% at least better than other years.